[Music]  Mariah Carey has officially left her 10  million dollar engagement ring from ex  James Packer behind it's a new start for  me really a rep for the singer tells ET  she recently parted ways with the 35  carat diamond and platinum bubble quote  mariah has been very vocal recently  about her choice to move forward in her  life surrounded by positivity that  requires leaving emotional and material  baggage behind after breaking off her  engagement to the Australian billionaire  in October 2016 Mariah kept the bling as  part of their settlement and according  to page six she recently sold the  Wilfredo Rosato designed ring for 2.1  million dollars to a jeweler in Los  Angeles all those moments are  bittersweet but you just have to focus  on whatever you're focusing on and keep  it moving  you